there was no shortage of Glitz but it
was a distinctly European feel this year
on the red carpet with filmmakers actors
and even Italy's far-right Deputy Prime
Minister one thing was lacking a big
Hollywood presence
despite highly anticipated film releases
the ongoing strike by American actors
and writers Banning them from promoting
films overshadowed the event
it may have brought the U.S
entertainment industry to a standstill
but in Venice there was support
I stand in solidarity with the writers
and the actors and like their fight is
the fight for all filmmakers and it's
against greed and profit
at the opening ceremony tribute was paid
to 90 year old Italian director Liliana
Cavani the first woman ever to win the
golden blind Lifetime Achievement Award
she called for greater recognition of
female filmmakers
[Applause]
there are women screenwriters and
directors who are working who probably
work just as well as the men if we look
at their work carefully if we give them
the opportunity to be seen this is
something I believe the festival should
consider
foreign
kicking off the festival the World War
II Drama by director Eduardo De angelis
commandante based on a historical event
it tells the story of an Italian
submarine commander who risked the life
of his crew to rescue Belgian Sailors
whose ship he had sunk in the Atlantic
other films making their debut in Venice
Priscilla director Sophia Coppola's film
based on the Memoirs of the wife of
Elvis Presley
Imagining the return of the leader of
Chile's military dictatorship Augusto
Pinochet as a 250 year old vampire
living in a rundown mansion
in spite of an absence of most American
filmmakers a message from this year's
jury president who was allowed to attend
as he wasn't promoting a film that's it
uh
buenasera
I think Fellini said it best
loud and clear
for all of Hollywood to hear Sonic
Gallego Al Jazeera